[Music]
ursula kayla green's third earth sea
novel the farthest shore
sees the arc mage sparrowhawk or ged
and his young companion from enlard who
is descended from the princes and indeed
all the way back to a great culture hero
his name is aaron
this young man going off on a quest
together to try to determine
the origin of this crisis whose effects
as we see developing through the novel
are getting worse and worse and worse
sucking not only joy and life and
direction but even magic out of earth
see
all through the agency of somebody who
is afraid of
death and afraid of life
and aaron pledges himself early on to
ged to be his companion
to
obey him to to show loyalty to him
but in the mid part of the work he goes
through we could say a crisis of
faith and
we see this depicted in very emotional
ways and so we can think about confusion
anger fear resentment even terror all of
these things come up uh despair as well
for for aaron and his commitment is
going to get tested as time goes on one
of the first things that kind of
prefigures what's happening is when he
asks the archmage they're both in
disguise and they're going to hort town
and he says
aren't you defended against thieves and
so on and sparrowhawks is defended what
do you mean do you think i go about
wrapped in spells like an old woman
afraid of the rheumatism i haven't the
time for it i i hide my face to hide our
quest that's all we can look out for
each other but the fact is we're not
gonna be able to keep out of danger on
this journey and then we see aaron
responding of course not aaron said
stiffly angered angered in his pride i
did not seek to do so that's just as
well the mage said and flexible and yet
with a kind of good humor that appeased
aaron's temper indeed he was startled by
his own anger he'd never thought to
speak thus to the archmage but this then
was and was not the archmage this hawk
with the snub nose and square ill-shaven
cheeks and
as we're going to see going on through
the story the shine that's originally
there on this great figure of the
archmage is going to start to
wear off and aaron is going to get
more resentful more fearful so you know
he's asking why doesn't gad actually use
magic when he can this will come up as a
sticking point later on and then the
biggest question is why does ged
take somebody who's clearly insane who
might knife them in the dark or push
them overboard or lie to them why does
he take a madman
on board and then we get to
this chapter this discussion
where what's going on with aaron is
being depicted
all right there's a lot of things going
on and i would say that we go beyond
doubt which gets mentioned
into actual despair with these voices
and this happens in a chapter called the
madman right
so aaron
is starting to think to himself he says
he hints of this and hints of that but
he'll never tell me clearly where we're
going or why or why i should go there
and now he drags this madman with us
which is mattis the lunatic or eye for
coming with him the two of them may
understand each other it's the wizards
who are mad now
and he goes on he says why did i come
with him why did he bring me because
it's my way to go but that's wizards
talk making things seem great by great
words the meaning of the words is always
somewhere else if i have any way to go
it's to my home not wandering
senselessly among the reaches and then
he goes on he says if he really thinks
there's some enemy of wizardry at work
why did he come alone with me he could
have brought another mage to help him a
hundred of them he could have brought an
army of warriors a fleet of ships is
this how a great peril is met by sending
out an old man and a boy in a boat this
is mere folly he is mad himself it is as
he said he seeks death he seeks death
and he wants to take me with him but i'm
not mad and not old i will not die i
will not go with him
so aaron is engaging in this interior
dialogue and later on just in the same
chapter
we see aaron saying to himself what a
fool he'd been to entrust himself body
and soul to this restless
and secretive man
who let impulse move him and made no
effort to control his life nor even to
save it it was clear now that to those
who knew the secrets there were not many
secrets to the art magic from which
sparrowhawk and all the generations of
sorcerers and wizards had made much fame
and power
there was not much more to it than the
use of wind and weather the knowledge of
healing herbs in a skillful show of such
illusions and myths and lights and shape
changes which could awe the ignorant but
which were mere tricks reality was not
changed there was nothing in majory that
gave a man true power over men nor was
it any use against death
even in small matters majorie was not
worth counting on sparrowhawk was always
miserly about employing his arts
and so
rn is now not just entertaining doubts
he is actually telling himself things
about this person that he's pledged
himself to so one of these is they're
crazy they're they're mad men they're
foolish
they make bad decisions
another is that wizards are big talkers
they
talk a good game but none of the things
that they say actually mean anything
their tricks are really just that just
tricks
illusions moving the wind around a bit
he's ignoring some of the key arts isn't
he summoning
changing
patterning and focusing on some of the
things that are taught
at rogue
he's also saying ged is indeed
seeking death seeking his death
and aaron doesn't want to die
he doesn't want to be dragged along
on this crazy thing that's not an
adventure anymore but now a mad quest
and this comes to a crisis in a very
physical way
at oberhol this island that soaply is
supposedly guiding them to
what we find is that spears are thrown
by the people on the shore
and soaply jumps off of the boat and
winds up drowning even though he's
afraid of the water he's more afraid of
death by getting speared
ged himself gets speared in the shoulder
and
pretty badly wounded aaron
is
stricken with emotions that he
can't really handle they manage to get
out
of the harbor and then they
they drift
what happens
well we find out
um
here we go
aaron
uh
takes the
the shoulder joint and collarbone and
starts tearing strips from a linen shirt
and helps him bandage the wound and
sparrowhack says i have no strength for
spells can you get us out of this bay
and rn
manages to do that and then
uh as ged starts to slip into
unconsciousness and the boat stops
moving we find this
all this while aryn had felt a sickly
heavy horror which grew on him and held
him from action
as if winding his body and mind in fine
threads no courage rose up in him to
fight against the fear only a kind of
dull resentment against his lot
he should not let the boat drift here
near the rocky shores of a land whose
people attacked strangers this was clear
to his mind but it did not mean much
that's really important the meaning of
things is ebbing away
what was he to do instead row the boat
back to rock he was lost utterly beyond
hope in the vastness of the reach he
could never bring the boat back through
those weeks of voyage to any friendly
land only with the mage's guidance could
he do it and sparrowhawk was hurt and
helpless as suddenly and meaninglessly
as soaply was dead
he says what did it matter there was no
good in anything no use the luck had run
out
hours went by the sun beat down the
grayish heat wrapped aaron round he sat
on moving a little bit later
we find that he's
sort of just giving up he looks at ged
with the clear eyes of despair and saw
nothing no memory stirred in him of the
fountain under the rowan tree or the
white mage light on the shade the slave
ship in the fog or the weary orchards of
the house of the dyers nor did any pride
or stubbornness of will wake in him
he watched on come over the quiet sea
where low great swells ran colored like
pale amethyst
there was nothing
a gap a void there were no depths
so
fortunately they're saved by
the children of the open sea and ged
is healed there and then there's a
confession of of what happened on his
part by aaron to
ged he tells him
um
here we go i betrayed your trust in me
god says how so aaron
there at obahol when for once you needed
me you were hurt and needed my help i
did nothing the boat drifted and i let
her drift you were in pain and i did
nothing for you
i saw land but i did not even try to
turn the boat
and get says
tell me what you thought at that time
aaron says nothing
nothing i thought there was no use in
doing anything
i thought your wizardry had gone no that
it had never been that you tricked me
i was afraid of you i was afraid of
death i was so afraid of it i would not
look at you because you might be dying i
could think of nothing except that there
was there was a way of not dying for me
if i could find it but all the time life
was running out as if there was a great
wound in the blood running from it such
as you had but this was in everything
and i did nothing nothing but high try
to hide from the horror of dying
and ged tells him
you didn't lose yourself
despair is something difficult for a
young person
to take on
you know
here we go 17 years give little armor
against despair
and aryan says i sought death and he
says no no you weren't you were you're
afraid of it so this is a very important
turning point emotionally in terms of
action
in terms of understanding himself in
terms of growth and in terms of the
relationship between
ged
and aaron
for this novel without going through
something like this rn would just be
a
sidekick through this he becomes
somebody
who can see the journey through to the
very end
beyond into the realm of death the dry
land and even out of that beyond that
all the way to the end of the novel
riding on the back
of the oldest dragon in existence
all that has to happen
after he goes through these doubts these
despairs his anger
and his fear he comes to know himself
through that
you